foreign
[Music]
they don't tip and the mark pretends to
bust tables so we can eat the buffalo
wings
no one is cheaper that has never not
worked
anybody can go eat scraps off you don't
have to you don't have to pretend to be
doing anything you can go up and go here
do you work here you can go hey
everybody I'm about to eat these scraps
and they'll go please don't but
go ahead they would have kick me out by
then but if you use a little finesse
you're in
the guy eating the scraps I've never
seen him before in my life did you ever
get to meet Michael Jackson ah damn it
man I wish I did though you know that
was what content when he died damn that
would have been the time to meet him
yeah yeah yeah man I want to say this go
ahead it is your sober birthday so happy
birthday
well finally something
oh my God something you know you're
that's that's something do you know you
didn't even wish me happy birthday on my
real birthday this year it's not the
same why I was born into the [__]
world yeah we all were
and I wish you Happy Birthday on your
[__] birthday yeah and I think I mean
thank you but
I mean what yeah
exactly I he wants a gift like there's a
Gucci or something no no he does no well
we got you a gift no that's not what I
want gift number one come on in we got
you gifts for your sober birthday here
we go oh I've always wanted one
how many wait sit down sit down
when you said you always wanted one what
what were you talking about a token a
token what
Egypt a token chip yes what it said you
weren't referring to a kind of person at
all what's your name Sam Sam I love Sam
when you said token
did you mean [__] this is a lot of chips
man yeah thank you so much why don't you
look Sam in their face and say thank you
I apologize
I'm sorry for what why are you
apologizing to him
for the years
uh we support cardi being offset and
their uh meal I think McDonald's should
do like the most controversial meal
Kanye West Kanye West would be a very
controversial meal but I think they do
the you know what if they got to give
everybody something do the Kyle
Rittenhouse meal
that's what it's lacking do a Kyle
Written House meal I used to do that
call and sick to work show do you
remember that yeah I'll go and do radio
drink on radio then go and do a show at
like 11 o'clock in the morning and I
tell everyone calls it to work on radio
I'll be like call stick to work meet me
at the club we're gonna do a Morning
Show and I did I did them all over the
place but I did one in Tampa
that they drank them out of booze before
I got to the club and man
it was evident that's when I gave out
your phone number
I gave out your phone number
and I gave and a guy was like I stood up
because I have stage for brain cancer in
the middle of the show and I was like
well let me buy you a drink he goes uh
Ramen Diet Coke I go sir making a Coke
and then he collapsed he hit his head
and he died like a week later
that's true that's true yeah that's yeah
his son called me he's like hey man my
dad was the guy at your show he's dead
yeah
cheers to that dude he was a [__]
cool dude front row front row front row
how old is he this is pretty old it was
like 50. that's not that old 6 56. he's
all like Rogan like old like Rogan
dude I haven't watched porn since August
that's not that long that's a pretty
[__] wrong
one
time I heard that the algorithm can tell
if you're gay before you know oh boy and
I was like I'm screws it's terrifying on
the internet yeah yeah why because just
by what you look at how long you hold
how long you stare at Mateo or whatever
you know if that's the case kind of
explains the videos
there's such a thing as an admiration
stare doesn't mean you're gay of course
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what's the procedure like
two in there yeah two I think it was two
two doctors
one was filming what are you gonna do
so wait you got the milking I got it did
you did it feel great because they
always say it's the best thing ever I
mean I must be free to get milked you
just got tested oh I didn't get milk
that's what I'm asking no yeah just go
and see if it's swollen or anything
that's like a rub and Tuck I don't think
that's what doctors do
his name could be Doc I figure I was at
the barber why not
no I get my prostate check because I'm
40 I was 46. you're 40 what 40. I just
turned 47 last week
it does die early
ring camera for geezers I'll be honest I
like seeing the stuff it's pretty fun
ring camera is pretty cool yeah I'd like
to get one you get one for your bedroom
we're gonna install a ring camera in
your room
Chris
remember the Russia gate didn't happen
you could talk to him yeah we have one
of those we have like an Arlo or
something on our house
because it's like kids won't be able to
sneak out anymore oh I catch kids well
teenagers you know what I mean what do
you want what do they do when they sneak
out you should go into the woods you get
drunk or something or you go like meet
your girlfriend in the middle of the
night you can get a discount no no but
like I'm saying that you can't exchange
what you know your finger and jerk off
it sucks yeah sick and then uh
yeah you can't well you could be a cool
player and have them come over to your
basement but guys look what you do you
do you be the coolest parent and then
set up some ring cameras
we're cooking
accidentally leave the mic on yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
last episode we had a debate as to who
could go the longest without burping or
farting because Tom accused me of
constantly farting constantly burping
blah blah blah and so we made we did a
handshake deal whoever could go the
longest through the episode without
burping or farting is the champion the
winner right now I lost apparently I
ripped a burp in the middle of not
apparently you know you did apparently I
lost because I just left apparently
because your honor
okay some evidence has come to light
thank you to our fantastically observant
ymh audience I was getting several DMS
several DMS saying that I in fact won
the challenge because at the 59 minute
mark
you burped
and then suppress the burp you looked
over and said does Christina notice that
I did oh
he suppressed the evidence your honor it
was used it's not first of all let me
point out how stupid this is
so if you how dare you if you suppress a
burp you're actually doing the polite
thing in other words
the audience noticed if the audience
noticed he burped in his mouth is what
I'm saying and he went
yeah okay give me used it a grotesque
version of it but if you happen to go
that's not this is
no I'm
oh
what she looks like she's gonna vomit
everything what is it no she goes last
night when you're in Bourbon you went
every single time you lurched forward
like you're gonna take a sip of the soda
I hate it take a sip of the soda I'm
gonna throw up is what I feel sick
watching her burp it's take a sip of
that are you vomiting or burping I'm
drinking
soda and I haven't tried the wine yet
why are you holding out I want to talk
about Hawaii oh my God
I have evidence your honor so to
Tom with my claim let's watch the actual
footage I'm gonna play the footage but I
went
early days of Ewing Rogan what is that
like like the first time you do it do
you think it's anything dude oh no oh
it's not how early were you yeah walk us
through the whole thing what was the Pod
like what it looked like Etc so [__]
cool yeah you'd go to his house he'd
meet you at the front door kids running
around wife dogs
and and well the first time I I was a
fan of the show so he invited me to do
the show uh I I can't tell you how early
it was it was early enough that no one
it wasn't like huge yet right he was
still he was selling uh flashlights on
it yeah he had ads and stuff flashlights
that was the specifics
Plus Size because Aubry Marcus right is
I think his dad ran sex stores right and
says
[Music]
[Laughter]
listen you got a great friend I just
want to let you know you have a great
time
get in here get in here
who loves you so much
[Music]
I've never seen I've never seen birth
look at this uncomfortable well I called
up Tom I said Tom well it is something
fun we could do
because he goes oh he hates balloons
you can't smell that you can't smell
that smells the balloons you can't smell
that
I'm being dead serious balloon they're
gonna start popping dude
they're gonna start popping I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to leave I'm just getting
serious
those aren't even Hot Lights yeah what's
gonna happen if they pop dude I'm just
gonna make a noise
oh dude what is
what is discreet okay it smells so much
better
no
are you being serious right now
he's shaking like [__] shaking
let's have it let's just have let's just
drink bro
this will calm your nerves here I'll
drink with you I'm shaking I'm like
shaking hold your hands
I know I know they're in here like I
know that it can happen again
that was Dove okay
[Laughter]
this kid what happened I don't know did
you watch it yeah nope oh no I never
watched that [__] movie I would never
watch that [__] movie
hey just do me a favor for real promise
me it's not coming back sweating
and why don't you like clown yeah you
can't trust them
yeah
you can't trust them you like the
gaudiness and abroad I I do there's a
part of me that really does it's called
the Trashy Side of me of course it's you
don't want it because you know it's
going to be a problem but like I think
you do know it's good if a girl's got
her name in her earrings it's going to
be a problem shout out to most of my
cousins by the way I can't wait till
America we love you I can't wait till
I'm digging one of her nails out of my
forehead I bet there's a part of that
that's so hot but also you're gonna
fight with that [__] lady in a
goddamn Applebee's pick up a bun and
whip it in your eyes you know yeah it's
going down in public for sure that looks
like a grown ass Jimmy Neutron
excuse me
[Applause]
Daddy can look like he'll be on the
reboot a full house get your Bob sagin
head ass
put your extra large head ass want to
say I got
my money stop eating
you put your head in Magnum condoms for
fun
how fun
you got super power tonight man you got
the three other ones the Ku Klux Klan of
gay [__]
oh my God looks like he'll let a black
[__] trick him out of twenty thousand
dollars
with you up here that makes it a kkkfc
[Music]
I was just listening to something that
they were saying that Russia and China
this guy predicted that Russia and China
will cease to exist in about 30 to 40
years because of their birth rate they
were saying that basically the China One
kid China rule that they had implied you
know uh years and years ago so many
Chinese no but they said that they lie
about their numbers that you think that
there's more than there are they said
that the problem is with China is 90 of
their population is like over the age of
40 or something like that so like you
can't you will cease to exist as a and
same thing with Russia yeah but again
these are look at the look at who this
is
these places where it's just yeah
there's articles all over the place that
say like that one China is ceasing to
exist as you read like is declining as
you're it's a new idea yeah but this guy
was on Joe Ryan are going to be here for
a long time
a little very very very long time
China's gonna be here
long time
China gonna love you long time Joe you
would have never really uh hung out no
never I no there was one time when we
went to uh some Diner after a comedy
show it was like you me Adam we did it
was like a group of people was it before
Workaholics it was yeah yeah you were a
dick
you know what I believe I believe dude I
believed you honestly was I dick you
weren't like super nice
let's walk through it let's walk through
it this is what okay I love it
it's a different man you know what Blake
I want you to be really honest with me
all right so what's the vibe you were
just kind of not at all interested in
who I was as a person oh that's the
common
um theme can I argue or no yeah it's
your life yeah yeah or now I go may I
argue against it sure all right
sure so
it's like like Blake right yeah you know
you're all right so let's say some guy
you're at a comedy club right and you're
friends with somebody and he's like I'm
gonna bring four other dudes to to the
diner sure right are you gonna be asking
questions to the other four guys you
don't know
um
I guess eventually
oh that was so cute like you cracked
your nuts
he was more like um deeply embarrassing
like just uh horrifying you know like
what he would embarrass you often as a
kid okay so he was in this band called
The vomitones and um they were called
the vomiting vomit yes so he thought
there was nothing funnier than puking
and um also the Queen of England he
thought there was nothing funnier than
the queen and British royalty and he
would have these dreams where different
civil rights leaders and blues musicians
were puking on the queen and he would
narrate them like if as if he was like a
sportscaster narrating like a baseball
game and he would narrate them so loud
that when I would have [__] a normal
sleepover my dad would be like ah all
right this is this is looking good here
guess who's gonna puke in the Queens
first Muddy Waters during a very
important ceremony Gotta Give him seven
points for that come on he got some on
her nose and she was holding the the
kind of the staff thing that means doing
this to himself himself fast asleep in
the middle of weird heinous like snoring
he would be like narrating these strange
vomiting trends
and like my friends could hear them I
just wanted like a normal dad that like
smelled reasonable and didn't wear like
a you know a vomitone's Hands Across
Uranus tour shirt that he would wear to
pick me up at school also it wasn't a
tour they played like two dive bars in
Michigan hey that's a tour that's a tour
give the vomitone some credit yeah they
got paid they went on the road baby they
lived that life I know you never know
but DeRosa now has taken over taste buds
and DeRosa now does he does taste buds
from Joey roses it's actually now it's
he just calls it taste bud okay it's
just taste argues with himself yes
that's what it is yeah Joe DeRozan
I will say one thing we did to observe
your death and honor you is in this last
eight weeks we never started the episode
with the song we never talked about Kane
Tanaka we never did any of the things
that you and I used to do we didn't we
didn't do any of that we did keep 100 of
the ad money but we didn't do
congratulations you just got done
watching 16 different clips from 16
different podcasts and now you yes you
get to vote on the funniest ones all of
these clips are going to be going head
to head in a bracket until just one
winner remains voted on by you guys the
joke World Community you can click the
link in the top of this video's
description right now to get involved in
the 2023 comedy March Madness tournament
tonight we're kicking off round one with
the sweet 16. each round will last three
days and whichever clip has the most
votes by the end of day three moves on
there's a total of four rounds taking
place over 12 days we have some really
strong Partners over at watch Comedy
live who custom built this bracket for
all of us so at least go check it out
please have some fun play around with it
tell your friends or family anyone who
likes comedy in your life that this is
going on just call them up say hey did
you know you know March Madness right
now with college basketball there's
actually one of those going on with
Comedy clips like our favorite comedians
all the funniest moments from 2023 it's
in a tournament isn't that so cool oh my
gosh that is so cool how'd you find out
about that I subscribe to this channel
joke world it's like the sports center
for comedy and it's the best part of my
entire life outside of all the joy that
brings me and keeps me in the loop with
all my favorite comedians it's literally
just you know the coolest thing ever I
wish I could subscribe 10 times to
everyone you know subscribe
say that to everyone you know on the
phone and then and then go vote on the
tournament
please
[Music]